[Music]
foreign
he doesn't seem happy hello Hank
you're supposed to be in Moscow I took a
detour
through your defense lap
tell me that isn't what I think it is
hands if you think it's a poor attempt
to replicate my work
even for this group I takes Nerf you
were instructed to go to Russia may I
remind you Dr Pym that you're a soldier
and a scientist then act like one the
pen particle is the most revolutionary
science ever developed help us put it to
good use let you turn me into your
errand boy
and now you try to steal my research if
only you'd protected Janet with such
ferocity talked to pimp
you mentioned my wife again
and I'll show you ferocity don't look at
me you said it
I formally tender my resignation we
don't accept it formally
Hank
we need you
the Pim particle is a miracle please
don't let your past determine the future
As Long As I Am Alive
nobody will ever get that formula
you shouldn't let him leave the building
you've already lied to him now you want
to go to war with him yes
our scientists haven't come close to
replicating his work you just kicked
your ass full size you really want to
find out what it's like when you can't
see him coming
I've known Hank Pym for a long time he's
no security risk
unless we make him one
[Music]